Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be a video all about Sansa
Stark and Littlefinger in season 7.
He is her final boss we gotta talk about why
she needs to take revenge on him there's going
to be a whole lot more game of thrones stuff
happening in the next couple months as they
wind down filming, so be sure to subscribe
to make sure you get all the Game of thrones
stuff.
There's a new round of the giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
I'm giving away copies of the enhanced editions
of the book, so I'll explain at the end of
the video but be sure to click that bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything.
So Catelyn Stark has this very important quote
when she's speaking to Robb Stark during the war of five kings
she's talking about the Lannister's in that
context.
But then later Littlefinger as he's talking
to Sansa trying to talk her into marrying
Ramsey, doesn't really give her much of an
option talks about taking revenge for her family
the real irony here is that everything that
Littlefinger has done instigating all the
major conflicts in Westeros has led to the
deaths of her family directly, so he is the
person she needs to take revenge against let's
take a trip through Littlefinger memory lane
going back to before the show started, so
you know about how he was fostered with the
Tully's with Catelyn and Lysa.
Lysa was obsessed with him.
He was obsessed with Catelyn but she was betrothed
to Brandon Stark when it was determined when
Catelyn would eventually marry Brandon in
the future Littlefinger outright challenge
him for her hand lost hardcore landed on his
ass looking at him today he probably wouldn't
last in the fight against Podrick, so they
gave him a day to recover.
He was only about 15 years old at the time
and then sent him away without getting to
say goodbye to Catelyn so he still obsessed
with her knew he wasn't going to be able to
get her because he was so low born.
So hatched his long-term con to make it to
the small counsel and orchestrated events
in the kingdom to bring about his rise to
the iron throne with Catelyn at his side.
He told that story to Sansa at the end of
season 6.
I have a dream in my head, me on the iron
throne with you beside me.
That was Catelyn in that dream until recently,
but going back in time when he was recovering
from his wounds with Brandon he slept with
Lysa she became pregnant, but her father forced
her to drink the moon tea so that deepened
her obsession with him use that later to orchestrate
the death of Jon Arryn.
He had a much bigger plan in place to destabilize
the kingdom during season 1 Jon Arryn was
just part of that but he convinced Lysa that
they could be together if he were to die.
So she poisoned him he dies orchestrating
the events that we see at the beginning of
season 1 where Ned Stark is brought to King's
Landing is the new hand of the king Littlefinger
is still the master of coin trying to deepen
the realms dead so that it will destabilize
and he can orchestrate a grand plan that would
culminate in him taking the iron throne but
there are a couple big steps along the way
he has to destabilize the kingdom he has to
throw them into war.
So he sells out Ned Stark.
So that's the first thing a really the biggest
thing that she should kill him for four orchestrating
events that led to the death of her father,
and then outright throwing him under the bus
but training him in the last moments the next
big slap in the face is when Littlefinger
comes to Catelyn during season two.
Offering Ned Stark's remains is recompensed
incomes under she rejects him outright.
This is the beginning of him shifting his
attention to Sansa start because she's growing
up.
She's looking more and more like Catlin and
then he comes to the conclusion during season
three that as he's been named Lord of Harrenhal
for brokering this deal with the Lannister's
in the Tyrell's.
He now has the power to move to the veil to
offer himself to Lysa Aaron who has no husband
right now.
So he thinks long-term that Sansa will be
a more powerful political marriage.
Then Lysa even though the veil has those forces
is still a very big place very important.
But it just a stepping stone to winter fell,
which was his ultimate goal, which is why
he sends her to Mary Ramsey in the way they
explain the TV show Littlefinger didn't truly
know how bad he was but he didn't seem all
that sorry are all that quick to help Sansa
when he heard about what was happening to
her.
So you don't really follow up on that until
season six when she looks like she's getting
ready to stab him in the face but is just
a prelude to what she's going to be doing
to him.
Later she fed Ramsey to his dogs.
Imagine what she's going to do to Littlefinger.
Eventually, but the whole point in putting
Sansa in winter fell was in regaining control
of winter fell via a political marriage that
was Littlefingers in had things not gone well
for him or had the battle of the Bastard's
gone the other way he would've immediately
turned tail and brokered an alliance with
the Bolton's so they could eventually form
another alliance with the Tyrell's and what
is happening now sort of the destabilization
of the throne in orchestrated events of the
call a great council and get everyone to trust
them so that he could present Sansa is the
next candidate for ruler of the realm with
someone else or eventually with him the problem
is is that she would need a suitor there's
a good book theory about Jon Snow or Aegon
being a Targaryen suitor for her in the books,
but because the TV show has changed.
Thanks so much.
I'm not expecting it to be even close to what's
happening in the books at every twist and
turn along the way and Littlefingers plan
to take the iron throne with Catelyn and then
eventually with Sansa has dealt their family
so many wounds that Sansa has a limitless
reasons to kill him.
So looking at her arc now.
She went from being this silly young girl
in season one to having the innocence literally
beaten out of her until today when she's learning
to play Littlefinger's game
so really the only thing is Sophie Turner
has said that Sansa wants is recognition and
what's going on her role in the battle of
the Bastard's the fact that she helped broker
the alliance that allowed them to win the
battle.
She doesn't seem to be getting that.
So even though she's a little upset with Jon
Snow and does not feel that he is fit to rule
the kingdom she isn't out to get Jon Snow
in the corner.
You can almost see the calculus that Littlefinger
is doing in his head, to try and turn the
situation to his benefit and that would be
turning Sansa against Jon snow but ultimately
they're family and what is the show done with
the big female protagonist the last couple
of seasons it shown them rising above things
tearing down the patriarchy.
So what would Sansa's next move then be it
would be to cast off her Littlefinger shackles.
But there couple things that she can do to
accomplish that one she could out him to the
rest of the kingdom he's responsible for orchestrating
all these terrible events Jon Snow would execute
him on the spot he was ready to execute Mela
Sandro on the spot if you were to learn about
Littlefingers responsibility in Ned Stark's
death that would be the end of it, there would
be no more conversation.
So let me know in the comments what you think
is going to have to happen before Sansa openly
moves against Littlefinger because right now
it seems like she's slowly using him as a
chess piece like he really wants her and she
knows that.
So she's going to try and use that to her
advantage, but something really big still
has to happen for she outright tries to kill
him and I would probably involve marrying
the sweet Robin, so that was secure that alliance.
She wouldn't need a Littlefinger anymore and
she would rule over the veil which is what
Littlefinger is effectively doing now as steward
for sweet Robin technically the other lords
of the veil really hate him because sweet
Robin likes and there's nothing that they
can do about it because he is so much influence
over him but if Sansa were able to turn sweet
Robin that they would need Littlefinger anymore,
so they're just a couple power plays left
in season seven for Sansa Littlefinger is
her final boss and getting vengeance and justice
for her family and everything that's happened
since the beginning of season one.
So there any other game of thrones season
seven or any other bonus videos you guys want
me to do this.
Let me know in the comments is going to be
so much stuff happening in the next couple
of months to get a trailer, really soon.
I know everybody wants to see some actual
footage from season seven they're almost done
filming right now will say congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner sort of the
morning, you win one of the enhanced additions
of the books please private message me on
the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details.
There's a new round in this video I'll announce
the winner the next time I post a game of
thrones video.
So really cool stuff coming, there was some
new Doctor strange Thor Ragnarok that just
dropped.
So that'll be my first video tomorrow, there
will be some new flash, and I'll just post
updates on bonus videos as we go along while
you wait for that you can click here to learn
about the brand-new Targaryen book George
RR Martin is doing later this year and you
can click here to learn about the extra episodes
and stuff were going to be getting during
season 8 of the TV show thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video!